luís díaz es el hijo ilustre de
barrancas este pueblo minero presume con
orgullo de ser el hogar de una de las
sensaciones del fútbol europeo su
llegada al liverpool ha desatado una
locura aquí todos dicen conocerlo mi día
es una persona sencilla muy sencilla un
gran ser humano
las primeras gambetas de louis fueron en
estas calles en donde ahora viven sus
abuelos su madre si leen es destaca
virtudes de louis que van más allá de su
buen manejo con la pelota fue creado ay
con mucho respeto con mucha disciplina y
por eso es que él está donde está porque
la disciplina es lo importante su padre
luís manuel lo llaman el profe lleva más
de 20 años dedicado a formar futbolistas
entre ellos a louis quien con 5 años ya
quería medirse con niños que doblaba
ansiedad soñaba que el barça que
liber que soñaba que el otro el atlético
con un tiempo pues decía pero llegó a un
élite llegó a uno de los mejores de
europa el liverpool
louis se destacó a nivel internacional
en una copa américa para los pueblos
indígenas en 2015 pero con 18 años tuvo
que abandonar su tierra natal para
probar suerte en las categorías
inferiores del junior de barranquilla un
equipo histórico de colombia sus
primeros entrenadores ya recuerdan que
desde el comienzo les llamó la atención
su desparpajo y capacidad para evadir
rivales todo el pool de entrenadores
como ese da cuenta que hay un flaquito
ahí que está
con mucha habilidad que está
descollando siempre mostró condiciones
resistentes fuertes y muy buenos en el
uno contra uno
su hermano jesús entrena sobre este
césped y bajo las órdenes de un
entrenador que conoce muy bien a luis
arturo reyes lo ayudo en su salto al
equipo de primera división y también fue
quien lo convocó por primera vez a la
selección colombia absoluta dice que su
talento para leer el juego es la clave
de su éxito le ayuda seguramente a esa
adaptación que no necesitó cuando llegó
a la primera vez a este equipo desde la
primera vez cuando pasó a júnior cuando
pasó a la selección mayor cuando estuvo
en el puerto y ahora en el liverpool
porque él depende de su habilidad
colombiano consiguió clasificarse para
el mundial de qatar y la afición
cafetera ven jugadores como luis díaz la
esperanza para regresar a la máxima cita
del balompié
verdaderamente louis nunca caminará solo